hey tasty fam
long time no see
hey guys it's keanu i am here in jaconi
my kitchen studio space and i'm going to
be teaching you today how i make some
incredibly delicious freezer breakfast
burritos plus added bonus my spicy
tomato
jam
super excited to share this recipe with
you guys so let's get started
to kick things off i want to show you
how to make the spicy tomato jam it is
so simple first thing i'm going to do is
chop up my tomatoes playing around with
knives is always fun
in the least creepy way i can ever pose
that
i generally like to make really big
batches of this so i have enough for my
burritos i can smear it on some
sandwiches so put these all in a bowl
try to save every drip of juice and i'm
gonna finely dice onion
get ready for the waterworks horizontal
slices across the onion and now i'm
going to put my knife vertically
and then i'm just going to slice going
as small small small small
as i can
ah
it
hurts so much
after i chop onions i banish them
temporarily from anywhere near my
line of sight
so i can cook in peace
oh
lord have mercy
should never wear mascara while cutting
onions
tomatoes are in onions are in
last chopping really is the chilies
now this is kind of like a choose your
own heat level
situation i like a little tangle so chop
them up super fine
so the final thing i need to cut is just
a lemon it just needs some acid to get
going and i'm just going to slice it in
half
i'm just going to put all the
ingredients inside so
the chilies the tomatoes the onions all
go in and the lemon juice i'm just gonna
squeeze it into my hand using my fingers
to catch
all the seeds so i have a teaspoon of
kosher salt going in if you're using
table salt you'll want to use less
and my spice you'll be using is ground
coriander ground cumin also is a great
substitute so about a teaspoon and a
half of that
and of course some sugar because what is
jam without a little sweetness
i have a cup of dark brown sugar and
then just give it a good mix so i want
to mix it up and you'll even see from
that sugar and like tomato juice
happening together it's kind of creating
a sauce and that's what you'll need
because to cook this is going to boil
now i'm just going to pop this on the
stove over medium heat for about 30 to
40 minutes and every so often give it a
little stir and then before you know it
you'll have some jam
it is burrito time i have my frozen hash
browns and bacon in front of me i'm
gonna cook them on some baking sheets i
have lined with parchment paper for easy
clean up so i'm just gonna cut these
open
spread them as thin as possible
i'm going to hit it with a little bit of
oil i'm using olive oil but you can use
any kind of cooking oil and just some
salt and pepper
you can use tater tots breakfast
potatoes and then on this other baking
sheet i'm just going to put my bacon
slices lay them one by one with no
overlap this works great with any
breakfast meat if you want to make it
veggie friendly on the stove you can
saute some mushrooms with some salt and
pepper
maybe a little bit of white wine in the
end because that
is quite delicious
and both of these are going to go in the
oven until these potatoes are nice and
brown
and this bacon is nice and crispy
bacon and hash browns are in the oven
and the jam is doing its magic on the
stove so time to do the eggs i'm just
going to do simple scrambled eggs i'm
making 10 wraps today so i'm going to
put about eight eggs in there so i just
crack it
on a flat surface
and boom and if you feel like having a
little fun in the kitchen you can try
doing it with one hand
oh gosh i hope this goes well for me
child's play and just whisk
until it is all homogeneous beautiful
yellow
i season them right in here
just salt and then i'm just gonna cook
them in a larger frying pan because
there are so many eggs i'm gonna put in
just a couple tablespoons of unsalted
butter
if you only have salted butter
then do not salt your eggs until the
very end because the butter may do the
job and you don't want to over salt it
so once the butter has these like tiny
foamy little bubbles it is ready for the
eggs i'm just gonna pour them in here
gently scrape the bottom going in
a little figure skater type motion so
a little figure eight here
a little dance around the pan and these
are gonna cook fairly quickly and you'll
see at every time you scrape will come
up in like little ribbons so the eggs
are 90 way the percent there there's
just the smallest amount of liquid left
so that's when i'm actually going to
take it off the heat
eggs are looking perfect it is time to
assemble these burritos
to wrap these breakfast burritos i am
using a flour tortilla now these are
like the little guys they're about seven
inches in diameter if you find your
tortillas are a little stiff what you
can do is microwave them for 10 to 15
seconds
that mobility and flexibility is gonna
help a lot when we're rolling and
wrapping first layer i like to spread on
some
cream cheese definitely less than you
would a bagel
so i go for just like a tablespoon of
cream cheese so i'm gonna go in with
a good spoonful of eggs and just like a
regular eating spoon is perfect to
measure the amount
so just spread that right on top of
where the cream cheese is one slice of
bacon
if you want you can chop it up and
crumble it a few
dollops of tomato jam have to
have to
put so much work into making it don't be
shy
and just a little bit of
that hash brown
nice and crisp
i like putting it on top of the jam
because it helps stick to it you know
and a few sprigs of cilantro so to roll
a burrito i want to make sure all the
fillings are facing horizontally across
and then i'm going to take the two sides
on the left and right and bring them in
and then take the bottom part of the
burrito
bring it all the way up to the top and
then this is where you kind of do like a
tuck and shove
and just squish it all in there
tucking in tucking in make sure those
cilantro leaves stay in and look a teeny
little teeny little burrito and then
seam side down into a hot pan and this
is going to seal it shut it doesn't go
anywhere so once the bottom is sealed
i'm just going to turn it
just to brown all the sides
so give a little crisp just going to
give it a little flip brown the other
side
so these burritos are looking good i'm
going to finish wrapping the rest of the
batch and then i will show you how you
can freeze them
so the burritos are wrapped and toasted
and before i freeze them i have to give
just one a try
oh my god that inside none
honestly feel no obligation to eat this
breakfast all day
lunch dinner midnight snack
i love these
so to wrap these burritos i want to
protect them from freezer burn so before
i toss them into a freezer bag i'm first
gonna wrap them in some plastic wrap pop
a burrito in
wrap it up nice and tight and you want
to make sure your burritos have cooled
down you don't want to wrap a hot
burrito
and then once they're all wrapped you're
going to take just a
big old ziploc bag make sure you write
the date
then you're just gonna pop it in here
fill it nice and tight and chuck it in
the freezer these can freeze for three
months and anytime you want a breakfast
burrito take one out unwrap it and pop
in the microwave and you have breakfast
anytime
if you do make them please show me tag
me on instagram i'd love to see what you
guys are cooking and let me know in the
comments down below what other freezer
friendly meals you'd like to see
until next time
bye oh yes
[Music]